hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the daily mirrors associate editor kevin
mcguire and the telegraph's assistant
comment editor olivia utterly there with
us now until midnight thank you both so
much for joining us let's take a look at
some of those stories that are on the
front of those pages and the telegraph
understands that plans for a 250 million
pound water plant that's supposed to
ease the burden of hosepipe bans
has been taken out of
service while the star hears that water
companies are encouraging people to
report their neighbors for flouting
hosepipe bans
that's also the lead story for the metro
while the times reports that millions of
people could be affected by the upcoming
bans
well according to the express inflation
could hit 15 percent by next year with
gas bills substantially to blame
the mail has the attorney general suella
braverman again pledging to curb
so-called wokism
the mirror features the swimmer adam
peaty calling on the government to
invest more in children's sports
facilities
especially following the lionesses
victory at euro 2022
the financial times has a story
concerning the relationship between the
holding company softbank
and the e-commerce conglomerate alibaba
and the guardian carries an
investigation which is found that the
far-right ecosystem is targeting
children in the uk
in an attempt to radicalise them online
while the sun reports that according to
rebecca vardy her husband the footballer
jamie vardy received death threats while
her court battle was ongoing
and reminded that by scanning the qr
code on your screen right now and that
you'll see it during the program you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
papers and look at them in a bit more
detail while you watch with us
well we are joined this evening by kevin
mcguire and olivia utley to take us
through got quite a good selection
tonight um kevin let's start with you
first of all uh
a big story tonight taiwan and what is
happening there we've seen this military
build up around the island of course
this coming in light of nancy pelosi's
whistle stop visit there a short visit
not a visit sanctioned by the u.s
government but she is the most senior
american politician to visit in a
quarter of a century
no absolutely and instead of a hornet's
nest and the the chinese are incredibly
belligerent and
threatening all sorts of retaliations
the guardian focuses on the fears that
there will be live firing exercises
around taiwan of course china has a much
much bigger state than uh than taiwan
it's itself and it could be it could be
a blockade
it was was the visit wise at this time
or was it was it unwise uh
because the position in the u.s of
course is uh it represents one china
doesn't have
an embassy in taiwan but at the same
time it sells the taiwanese
arms and it's clearly a huge issue for
the chinese although i would say if if
beijing wishes to woo
the taiwanese i'm not sure is going to
happen the right way about it when it
seems to be
all all threats but of course it goes
back to what was effectively a
politician of china in 1949 when the
nationalist cayenne czech lost the civil
war fled to taiwan the chairman of the
communists one on the mainland and
beijing
looks like it uh it's going to step up
its campaign to reunify china but again
i just think it's kind of good about it
a very uh very um positive way and the
example of hong kong which of course had
to go back because it was a british
colony had been seized by by britain in
the past went back the erosion of
freedoms there is not going to encourage
the taiwanese to want to embrace the
mainland
and olivia a lot of people will look at
this and say well you know it's an
awfully long way away it doesn't really
concern me but but
any destabilization in that region is of
course a great cause for concern isn't
it
well massively and this looks like
taiwan is on the verge of being
completely blockaded um taiwanese people
could
find it difficult to get hold of food
supplies etc um that's pretty scary um
and
we did know you know when when we saw um
putin invade ukraine they were they were
it was said that it would embolden other
dictators to do something similar and
obviously the these tensions have been
bubbling for a while now but it now
looks quite likely that china will mount
a full-scale invasion even of of of
taiwan um soon and i think nancy
pelosi's visit was was was really very
misguided of of course she should be
able to visit taiwan of course most you
know right think me people believe that
taiwan should should have
self-determination be its own separate
state but the truth is that
the the us has maintained this position
of
careful ambiguity for years now and
that's
very important diplomacy and nancy
pelosi just seemed to want to look good
on the world stage do a bit of virtue
signaling and treated it a bit like a
kind of catwalk for herself it's a
freelance diplomacy um and i think that
it's the taiwanese people who are going
to suffer as a result of that
we shall see um thank you both very much
for that let's move on to another really
big story which we've of course been
covering for the last few days uh and
which we've had developments on this
evening and and that's that the story of
archie battersby and the fight for his
parents to to keep his life
support system going uh olivia tonight
we we've heard that that another legal
bid has failed the hospital have said to
his parents look you know
if we don't hear anything different from
nine o'clock tomorrow morning it looks
like from 11 that we will start to to
progress that the turning off of his
life-saving equipment
it's heartbreaking isn't it and any
parent will watch what's happening and
your heart goes out to these parents but
it does seem that they have reached the
end of the road doesn't it in terms of
where they can go legally
yeah it does look like they have and it
really is just such a horrible story and
when and when you see those interviews
with his mother who who genuinely
believes that that actually there is
life left in archie and that one day he
might recover um and the the courts are
telling her and all the medical evidence
too seems to be telling her that that
that's just not the case but it must be
just un indescribably awful to to feel
as she clearly does that that it's her
family against the whole legal system
and she's taking it as far as she can
possibly go at every single stage that
family's love for their son is is just
incredible to to witness really but it
looks that they're now talking about
transferring archie to hospice care
they're going to do it tomorrow so his
father can be by his side um it's just a
really tragic tragic story
and it's it's sad isn't it kevin i mean
the the actual circumstances of this
case
you know aside that
that they felt that they have to take
this action that that perhaps those last
few days that they could have spent
with archie that they've they've spent
embarking on this legal challenge
yeah just decisions are taken in the uh
the nhs and the healthcare system to
switch off life support machines
probably every day and they're done in
consultation with families and there's
often agreement i was on the periphery
of a decision like that once and and it
is it's heartbreaking and your heart
goes out to holly dance and
paul uh buttersby the the the dad uh
both devout christians uh
they believe that
you know that their son is better than
all medical experts say he is and the
failure to get a hearing at the european
court on human rights which said it
wouldn't interfere because it believes
the
law has been followed correctly is it is
a big blow to them and uh holly the
mother is now talking about trying to
get a
charlie's uh sorry an archie's law to
help uh help other families but
the fact is
he's dead he's just he's dead he's just
being kept in some sort of condition
with the uh with the mechanical
ventilator um
and the hospital say even trying to move
into a hospice would uh would uh result
in a deterioration so
it's she's she's accepts it's the end
but you you can understand her age you
can you might even feel it yourself if
you were a parent that way um
but uh at the end of the day the
decisions have to be taken for what are
considerably the best interests of uh
of the patient in this case a child and
something unspoken but is always in the
background is the strain on the nurses
and the doctors tending somebody who is
effectively dead but has just been kept
going in some way or officially
and also the strain on nhs resources if
somebody's been in intensive care uh
treated like that for four months but
they're dead how long do you
how long do you go on that means
somebody else can't be receiving
receiving treatment it's it's it's sad
it's tragic
and there's no easy answer at all with
this
at all whatsoever um yeah um let's move
on to something well slightly lighter
perhaps but but actually not not that
light quite significant for a lot of
people we're all seeing yellow lawns
everywhere yellow parks everywhere uh
the country's really suffering because
of the hot weather uh but there's the
daily telegraph's got a story about a
water plant that was designed especially
to to kick into action when this sort of
thing happens um but it's been secretly
mothballed kevin tell us more
yeah thames water 250 million
desalination plant the telegraph says
was opened by principal in 2010 but it
isn't operating now and he could have
produced fresh water from beckton in
east london the old the docks area for
four hundred thousand uh homes according
to the target
of course in one way that's only a
drop in the ocean uh should we say when
there's 15 million homes in thames temps
water
alone whereby it looks like we're going
to be told not to wash our cars or i
never do mine uh or water or lawns i
thought you just had a bike kevin
you know yeah i i've used my bike
actually well if you could watch a bike
i don't even probably need clarification
on that jane whether you're allowed to
go out with a sponge and clean your body
but you would think if they've spent all
this money on this plan why isn't it why
isn't it operating if it could turn sea
water into fresh water well exactly why
why is it operating olivia you know it's
your paper that have got this great
story what what's going on here
well it's not exactly clear there's an
editorial on it as well and it turns out
that there are these plants operating
perfectly effectively throughout
most of the world but somehow
mismanagement has left this one in a
state where it's about to be mothballed
and from from the story it sounds very
much as though as though thames water is
just very badly managed and of course we
have had the driest july um for a very
long time um and we're set for a very
dry august as well so the conditions are
bad but the truth is that thames water
loses a lot of water every year to leaks
and doesn't do enough to fix them
quickly and at the same time as is
profiting quite a lot so i don't think
that's water is in a particularly good
state and if it's not able to run this
desalination plant which you know as
we've heard cost
250 million in 2010 and has barely ever
been used it's not it's not clear it was
it's ever been in in full in full use in
those 11 years um it's
it's quite bad so it both liz trust and
richie suno let's trust in this question
in the telegraph uh tomorrow as saying
that she's going to look into this
properly but it feels like another
reason why i can't believe how long this
leadership contest is dragging out for
you know issues like this are exactly
what the prime minister should be
tackling head on right now um in another
month's time this drought will probably
be over it'll have rain
but it briefly brings us on to well
here's hoping just before we take a
break at the daily star on the metro
both covering
linked story to this which is that
there's going to be um hotline to grass
up your neighbors that's the metro's
take on it but the daily star
have gone for this glorious image this
is of course is what all grannies look
like uh spot those were saggy
pop socks rollers in the hair um yeah
this is what all of us are watering our
lords look like of an evening grass of a
granny is the star's take on that uh spy
on neighbours over host pipe band right
we're going to take a short break
but coming up
after the break could inflation hit 15
by the next year the express seems to
think so
we'll discuss that next
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now kevin mcguire and
olivia utley are taking us through uh
front pages and some of the things in
besides insides as well um kevin let's
go to the express now um
this is about inflation potentially
going up to as high as 15
according to uh this is the resolution
foundation today wasn't it giving this
forecast it's been terrifying
absolutely i think tank that focuses on
low and middle income families and 15
percent inflation like it's up to 9.4
percent already on the consumer price
index uh more than eleven percent on the
retail price index which wider includes
some housing costs uh poorer people are
facing around twelve percent already
because they spend a higher proportion
of their money on food and energy which
are driving this big rise and fuel bills
i mean that is absolutely horrific and
tomorrow we have the bank of england
possibly putting up interest rates by
half a percent where the cure for high
inflation if the cost of borrowing in
mortgages go goes up and up starting in
the funding income as well that can be
just as as painful uh
as inflation itself which would be
intended to be brought down but it's a
terrible position why is the uk economy
in in this in this state well you could
certainly point to brexit you could
point to covert you could point to
putin's invasion of ukraine but as also
we've had 12 years of very very low
growth low productivity it's all coming
home now and people are really really
suffering
uh very very briefly olivia before we go
this half the mirrors front page and
this is about adam peaty uh who's really
cross about the lack of investment in
sports facilities and of course we're
thinking about the lionesses win they've
petitioning both uh liz trust and rishi
sunayak to make sure that all girls have
access to football um do we think that
something positive is going to come out
of this that we are going to see
children getting better facilities
oh yeah i think 100 and you've got the
drive there as well and you're already
seeing girls i've been seeing girls out
in london dressed in football kits like
for the first time i can remember so i
think that a lot of positive will come
out of this and i think the sports
facilities will definitely be a
very good good
innovation